hello good morning the home office says
it is determined to do more after sky
news filmed two overloaded dinghies
crossing the channel under the noses of
french police officers questions are
being asked about cooperation between
the english and french authorities over
the number of migrants heading to
britain the uk pays the french
government millions of pounds to try to
prevent migrants crossing despite the
home secretary pretty patel promising
new sea tactics to turn back boats it's
been the busiest year on record for
crossings well our correspondent adam
parsons has this exclusive report from
ambletuce in northern france
cross-channel migrants normally operate
in the shadows of night but this is
something profoundly different
dozens of people we're told that they're
all iraqi kurds carrying a boat down a
beach in northern france determined to
set off for britain
this was a chaotic caravan of people and
possessions three small children among
them
meandering towards shore
and ahead of them
one of the most dangerous journeys
imaginable
these people have paid thousands for
their place on this boat
40 of them clustered onto this one
overloaded vessel
well they've carried this huge boat all
the way down the beach and got it in the
water and over there
is dover and the french police have
watched all of this happen
and haven't lifted a finger to intervene
this was as near as they got maybe 100
meters away incongruously equipped with
riot shields and helmets but not getting
involved
it took 10 minutes to get the engine
started this was not a frenetic process
but then they were gone
chugging off towards the kent coast
[Music]
and this wasn't even the first packed
boat to leave this beach
one had gone half an hour earlier
similarly laden with people
it can be a time of brutal decisions
some people left behind
and look here the man on the left stands
up and is then pushed into the water and
left to swim back to shore
and all this also ignored by the
watching authorities
we followed both vessels as they tried
to cross the channel
the engine is still struggling the
skipper of our boat fears either it will
overheat or the dinghy will capsize
so we've already alerted the french
coast guard to its whereabouts and
condition
but that's not the only problem
the channel is the busiest shipping lane
in the world it's perilous and here's
why
as the boat continues its slow journey
a 400 foot long tanker approaches at
speed
if there's a collision it would be
catastrophic for everyone on the dinghy
the big ship
might not even notice
[Music]
the channel was busy thanks to calm
waters and fine weather possibly a final
chance for migrants who spent the summer
waiting for an opportunity to reach the
uk
we saw other dingies making the crossing
smaller ones carrying many more people
than they should have done
and also this
the 200 euro inflatable kayak being
paddled across
these men have come from east africa now
with no life jackets
they are risking their lives to get to
britain
they streamed into ports in kent boat
after boat accompanied by border force
lifeboats and coast guard
their journey's over it might have taken
months or even years at great risk and
at hefty costs
there's little sign of this flow slowing
or being slowed
adam parsons sky news ambulates in
northern france
well we asked the home office for a
response to adam's report the
clandestine channel threat commander dan
omoni told us we are seeing an
unacceptable rise in dangerous channel
crossings and we are doing everything we
can to support the french response so
they can do more to stop people making
these unnecessary journeys our joint
co-operations led to nearly 300 arrests
65 convictions related to small boat
criminality and more than 13 500 migrant
attempts prevented so far this year but
we are determined to do more well aisha
saheed is in dover for us this morning
it was pretty foggy uh in large parts of
the county overnight wasn't it
it's cleared now but but how is the
weather and i'll have they seen any
crossings attempted yet
so we haven't seen any crossings
attempted yet but i think we can
definitely expect more to happen today
the waters are expected to be a lot more
calm this weekend and it may well be the
last chance for people to try and make
the crossing before the weather turns
and autumn draws closer in and we enter
winter months because it is an
incredibly treacherous journey with
karma waters it's that slight bit easier
but it's the busiest shipping lane in
the world when and when people get into
trouble it can escalate into really
really big danger very quickly so it's
just been another summer pass without
any resolution to the problem it's been
a record year for migrant crossings if
we take a look at some of the numbers
more than 17 000 people have attempted
to cross the english channel so far this
year that's already double more than
double the figure for the whole of last
year when 8
417 people risked their lives to make
the crossing
and the record for a single day was set
on the 21st of august when
828 people arrived within a 24-hour
period and now it's going to be
particularly concerning for the
government especially after we saw that
footage yesterday of people making those
journeys in broad daylight with french
authorities stood by and not intervening
because pretty patel has taken a tougher
stance on the issue she handed the
french authorities 54 million pounds
only months ago to increase surveillance
of the area and double their patrols on
beaches
so so it's going to be a particular
concern for the government and i as i
said i think we can expect more
crossings to be made today
aisha thanks very much
well reminder that the great debate is
coming up on sky news on monday night
trevor phillips will be asking does
britain work without immigration our
panel will be discussing the economic
and cultural impact of immigration and
asking whether the end of free movement
post-brexit has damaged the uk that's at
nine o'clock on monday
also making the news this morning the
social media giant facebook has suffered
a second major technical failure in one
week the companies issued an apology
saying that the two-hour downtime was
caused by an error during routine
maintenance
senior u.s officials will meet taliban
representatives to discuss the
evacuations of foreign citizens from
afghanistan it'll be the first
high-level talks between the two sides
since the u.s pulled out of afghanistan
in august
china's president xi jinping says that
reunification with taiwan must and will
be realized his comments were made 24
hours ahead of celebrations marking the
110th anniversary of taiwan's creation
something still strongly disputed by
china
the taiwan question is purely an
internal matter for china
one of which needs no external
interference
no one should underestimate the resolve
the will and ability of the chinese
people to defend our national
sovereignty and territorial integrity
the complete reunification of our
country will be and can be realized
well our correspondent tom cheshire is
in beijing and tom this
isn't how many people in taiwan see it
and and they're having to put up with
chinese flights uh military flights uh
very nearby aren't they
yeah taiwan is certainly feel the
pressure and if that view of the great
hall of the people in beijing all those
delegates need to not lean rose the
exact opposite of what taiwan really
wants it's a thriving democracy it's a
self-governing island and it has been
for some time but there is that pressure
from china we saw record-breaking
flights starting with china's national
day last week culminating in more than
150 sorties on one day a new record and
it did feel like tensions were getting
worse and then you have a statement like
that today from xi jinping and that
might make you think the worse as well
but actually what he's saying when he's
talking about the reunification as uh
china puts it um is very long-standing
it's baked into the chinese constitution
it's even passed laws that it needs to
take taiwan by force if peaceful means
fail i think what was striking though
today was the xi jinping actually dialed
it down slightly it felt like he was
stepping away he mentioned peaceful
means three times he didn't even mention
the use of force that is unusual in july
he was talking about smashing any
attempts at taiwan independence were to
taiwan formerly to declare itself so it
does feel like there's a slight walking
back there um trying to understand why
uh it might be that he wants to get
people back in line more sort of hawkish
uh national security establishment
that's just a much of an issue here in
china as it is in other parts of the
world but it might also be to do with
u.s china relations the u.s of course is
very very important in this um it's
never said whether it would defend
taiwan it's always maintained strategic
ambiguity but there was a meeting in
zurich this week between top uh security
advisors both china and the us and that
meeting seems to have gone rather well
certainly a lot better than meetings
we've seen in the past between china and
the u.s state media here uh giving very
rosy reporting around that so taiwan
would have been a topic for discussion
there and perhaps that's a reason for
the slight softening of tone we've seen
now tomorrow is taiwan's national day of
course we'll see if there any other
comments on the basis of that and the
statue situation does still remain very
tense there's a lot of military hardware
in the region and mistakes could happen
but it does feel like a bit of a walking
back a glimmer of optimism uh for a
situation that is still very dangerous
tom thanks a
lot now despite a fire at the ground
where they will meet england will face
andorra in a world cup qualifier today
the blaze broke out in the television
gantry at andorra's national stadium
firemen managed to bring it under
control officials say the game will kick
off at 7 45 is scheduled
the education secretary is expected to
make the reduction in persistent pupil
absence as a key priority in a speech to
head teachers later today nadim sahabi
will say that disadvantaged children
lose out most from not being in school
well i'm joined now by the president of
the national association of head
teachers tim bowen um mr bone uh what
kind of reception will the deems the
harvey receive do you think
i think he'll see receive a positive
reception i mean he's only obviously
been in post um just a few weeks the
fact he's chosen agreed to come to our
conference this will be the first
opportunity he's had to speak to members
of the teaching profession in our case
school leaders so we very appreciate
appreciate the fact that he's coming to
uh talk with us he hope he will listen
to us and start to engage with us so we
can begin to rebuild a relationship of
what we hope will be trust and respect
with the dfe that's been uh badly
damaged over the past year and a half so
we're very grateful that he's coming
he said that he will pursue tirelessly
pursue the root causes
of those children who are repeatedly
absent i mean do we need more research
into this to look at the causes or do
teachers pretty much know what's causing
it and just need some money to be able
to deal with it
yes i mean i would say um that
absenteeism it's not a widespread
problem in the sector um but we hope
that whatever mr harway develops in this
area that he does so in conjunction
working with school leaders so that he
gets it right um
we feel that you know obviously we
haven't seen the detail of what he's
going to say yet but uh certainly
excessively punitive measures if they
were leveled at schools or parents
seldom have the desired effect um
support not sanction is the right way to
go and yes schools certainly would know
the families and most probably the
reasons for persistent absenteeism and
more people such as family support
workers to engage with those families
working with schools would um in many
cases support
you say it's not a widespread problem do
you think the education secretary is
focusing on the wrong things
well as i say we haven't seen the
precise details of of watty of what he's
focusing on i mean one of the biggest
problems with absenteeism at the moment
and i will just mention this is related
to kobe there's been a significant
increase in the numbers of pupils um off
school due to covet related now that
obviously is slightly different but what
we will be impressing on the secretary
of state
is to look at changing
the rules so that where children can
come into school if siblings in their
family have covered at the moment if a
child has covered and they may share a
room with a brother or sister who are
able to come into school and we're
concerned that this is increasing the
risk of kobe spreading in schools so we
will be asking him to look very
carefully at the rules there to try and
keep children safe in school we all want
children in schools clearly for as much
of the time as possible and we look
forward to working with him on this
what can schools do to help children
catch up and how
how freely available are the resources
to do that
well as you say first and foremost
children need to be in schools i think a
smaller group smaller class sizes
individual tuition um and also working
with children on supporting their
personal their social their mental
health and well-being a number of
children have um had you know difficult
experiences in lockdown so the more
support we can give him we would like to
see an increase in the mental health
support teams in schools my school in
saint auburn's we were one of just 20 of
schools that were fortunate enough to
have a mental health and support team
connected with our school it did have a
significant impact positively both for
pupils and parents but only 20 of
schools had these so we would like to
see significant investment so that
mental health support teams can be
available not just to a fifth of schools
but to all schools
okay good to talk to you tim bowen from
the nht thank you thank you
the british army is encouraging more
women to sign up it says that there's a
range of different roles available and
insists opportunities are the same for
everyone women played an important part
in sensitive operations like operation
pitting the evacuation mission from
kabul as jemima walker reports captain
rosie wilde is the only woman to have
passed the army's grueling parachute
regiment entry course for the light
people i might be i might be carrying
about 100 kilos um and some of the guys
might be carrying some 40 or 50 kilos
first and foremost she is a soldier
but when her regiment was deployed to
kabul in august she says female troops
dealt with extra layers of complexity
750 troops from the 16 air assault
brigade deployed 20 were women that's
around 3 percent i think that we've
learned a lot from it we've learned a
lot that with a
non-combatant evacuation operation we
are looking at different types of people
we are looking at people with cultural
sensitivities we're looking at more
women more children and in the future
would it be better to have more women
there yes potentially but i certainly
think that on the ground the 20 women
that deployed did an excellent job
actually managing managing the people in
kabul
those cultural sensitivities meant
female troops could step in where their
male counterparts couldn't and for the
women in particular it was understanding
those sensitivities and being available
to the women who might need more help or
to the women and children that required
female support whether that was the
searchers or the medics who were poor
pillow to post looking after women
children
and their families sergeant ashley
fenwick is a military police woman in
kabul she was stationed in the
evacuation center
searching families before they boarded
planes in a row that we were in
it was female searchers to search the um
the women their husbands wouldn't
wouldn't allow for
a meal to search their their their wife
so that's where we would step in and
search the search the women and search
the children i think that them seeing a
woman as well it sort of put them in it
it would put a lot of people out at ease
they found a lot more comfortable as
well to to relax and so when you were
searching people i mean there were a lot
more male troops than female troops
was your line
a lot longer than everyone else it could
be at times yeah the army is encouraging
more women to sign up for all roles the
opportunities available to women in the
army are the same as the opportunities
available to men
in an age of constant global competition
it's the quality and diversity of our
people that gives the british army its
unique edge
females have only been able to apply for
all roles in the army for three years
before 2018 they were barred from some
ground close combat roles
operations like pitting show how crucial
it can be having women on the front line
jemima walker sky news
let's go look at the weather now
well there's plenty of fine weather to
come this weekend but a weakening cold
front will bring some rain as well as
lower temperatures to more typical
values
much of ireland northern ireland and
scotland will have a cloudy and breezy
start today as overnight rain continues
to push south eastwards
most of the places will be rather gray
and mild with just the odd spot of rain
and any fog patches over central and
southern england will gradually lift to
warm sunshine
[Music]
andy tell us a little bit about what you
guys do here and how you're trying to
make heading the ball safer for
everybody so we've developed a training
platform designed to help players learn
how to head the ball in a step-by-step
process designed by uefa pro coach easy
way for a licensed coaches all of the
steps that you should take to safely add
the ball
the system itself if you're using it in
training you're doing two things with
one you're reducing the number of
impacts and the other one is because of
the realism of the system you're still
able to increase the skill level that
the players develop
what we're trying to say is if there's
10 headers a week that you're allowed to
do now we can help maybe give you 200 a
week
how mobile can you be do you need to be
in your house and it's totally wireless
you can use it anywhere like your
bedroom you could use it out in the
garden or you could use it in a living
room and that's going to be teaching you
how to head a ball better and you said
before that you weren't great at it so
we'll by the end of the day we'll have
you walking out and scoring worldies you
can like smooth out this 50p head we'll
see what we can do where am i here by
the way this is just our training center
we're not going to replace anything
we're there to complement what's
happening at training grounds already
all you've got to do is the ball's going
to come out of that circle and you've
got to head it straight back in so it's
like infinite head tennis oh
there you go
feel free to move around plant your feet
again if you want to just get
comfortable and just get used to heading
the ball recent research has come out
that shows that players are more likely
to suffer with conditions like dementia
about three and a half times more likely
we're seeing versus the general
population now that's been linked to
heading the ball so it's obviously an
issue from a player welfare point of
view and it's something that authorities
are starting to take very seriously if
you put power in it will come out back
at you faster
and if it spins it'll challenge you a
bit harder as well so it's trying to get
you to put the ball right down the
middle of that circle people have been
looking into this for about 20 years now
the last 10 years the research has
really started to ramp up and we're
seeing real life stories now with the
likes of dennis law and tony mcdermott
there's that piece around player welfare
that the authorities just have to take
seriously they have to look at
mitigation strategies trying to reduce
heading probably in training which is
where we can control it much more
it's probably a sensible place to start
i mean i've not counted how many you've
done in this but
i'm pretty certain there's a lot more
than you would do in an average training
session straight away yeah a lot better
than it would be in average transition
as well well there you go that's because
we're basically planting you in the
right formation delivering the ball
right to your head yeah 21 in a row
which is pretty good notice the
trajectories are altering you have to
move your body a lot more now and
they're making a lot of weird faces
everyone does don't worry have you ever
seen photographs of people when they're
headed in a ball they're not pretty no
so no again that's how accurate is very
realistic it's the same stuff that is
being used a couple of premier league
training grounds close to us where we
are now it's built for kids of all ages
to just take that first step the
tutorial in it is very basic it will
tell you how to just stand how to
observe how to keep your eyes on the
ball and all those little tips that you
know you should be getting at that age
group and it will just give you the
ability to head the ball maybe 500 times
without taking a single hit you know and
that's really important at that age
group we can put it on hard if you want
no that was pretty hard i think that was
the hard mode what do you think it's
pretty good in it give me two minutes
i'm in i'm in
we're all in to kick it out partnering
to end racism in sport your final film
no time to die is it different from bomb
films before is it
going on with a bang
yeah definitely definitely definitely we
pulled out
all the stops for this one and
bomb movies are bomb movies they're not
like nothing else and and i will miss it
um and probably will be when they cast
the next person be you know a bit like
but
i'm okay with it i'm like
i've done it i've done i've done five
it's plenty uh
this movie like we said i think i think
it's
it's really good i'm very proud of it
and
i'm happy to kind of get on with things
now
it may now give you time to watch your
football club liverpool
yeah hopefully yeah i mean do you think
there's there's a chance of reclaiming
that title back this season
i do yeah i think it's a really big
chance yeah
i mean i was just we were talking just
before we uh we started this about the
crystal palace game i thought that was
one of those of just like
a really big signifier we can do it
because if we can gouge those games out
we can do anything
liverpool be manchester city has been
the real big battle
morning
i'll join later
always got good advice that girl this is
sky news breakfast coming up the power
of social media how
one boy with autism had his birthday
wish come true
[Music]
[Music]
well let's return to those images that
we brought you earlier of migrants
leaving the french coast watched by
police and unchallenged by the
authorities thousands more have made it
to britain this year compared to 2020
often coming ashore on the beach at
dungeness in kent and their continued
arrival has frustrated the authorities
and divided those who live nearby as our
communities correspondent lisa holland
reports
the days are getting shorter the sun is
rising later and yet another summer has
passed without resolution to the small
boats crisis
first light and we spot a recently
abandoned dinghy the disregarded clothes
and a blanket are still wet
we counted at least 10 life jackets the
people who wore them have now moved on
but they've left behind communities
which whilst largely empathetic appear
exhausted divided and frustrated after
the uk committed nearly 200 million
pounds to the french over the last six
years to help break the cycle
mike golding has lived here for more
than 40 years and says it's become
normal to see migrants arriving on the
beaches
we've got to feel sympathy for them but
you've got to draw the line and um
how many are you going to look into the
country and what you're going to do
about it to stop them the french are not
going to do anything um they want rid of
them as much as we don't want them are
you kind of resigned to the way things
are yeah very much so nowadays you just
take it for granted they're going to
come
and that's it really nothing we can do
at this level but others can't contain
their anger and are turning their
frustrations directly onto the migrants
lawbreakers shouts one woman
they're coming in now to land
can you tell me why you're here
another local resident kim rai films as
she challenges new arrivals on the beach
at dungeness a few weeks ago was france
not a nice country to live in
it's organized it's organized crime it's
divisive as well
we went to see kim and her husband
graham who say they want to make it
clear they welcome what they call
genuine refugees but admit their
attitude to asylum seekers and in
particular economic migrants is hostile
young men
getting off a boat and strutting up the
shingle wearing nike trainers carrying
smartphones
i'm sorry but that's not a refugee
oh are you pleased to be here of course
we are if you lived through this every
day if you're listening to the
helicopters going up the police sirens
and that's why i'm angry i feel very
protective of this community nobody
knows who those people are they don't
know who they are they don't know where
they've come from the longer it goes on
the greater the chance is that something
nasty will happen somebody coming up
that beach tooled up with ak-47s
that's not the way everyone views the
migrants
terry preston has lived on this coast
for most of his life it's very divisive
and it certainly divided the community
we
need to treat these people with
compassion and justice and of course
there's got to be an immigration system
we can't in this small island take
everyone who comes but there's got to be
a compassionate way in which that's
dealt with
the government says it's determined to
tackle the rise in channel crossings but
without a significant shift in policies
they're likely to remain the backdrop to
the lives of those who live in these
coastal communities lisa holland sky
news kent
now kevin harrison tweeted a heartfelt
request on behalf of his son daniel who
was celebrating his 16th birthday he
posted that daniel was autistic and that
it was his birthday wish to make some
friends the response on social media was
heartwarming to say the least while the
legendary star wars star
mark hamill luke skywalker as he's best
known said for my friend daniel the
force is strong with this one
and russell crowe of gladiator fame said
happy birthday daniel
well dad kev joins me now uh lovely to
talk to you kev you must have been
thrilled by the response why did you
decide
to put it out there to tweet about
daniel
i just wanted to make people aware of
not just the plight of people like down
or my son daniel but other children in
the same situation
i thought
we've been through this journey now for
a long long time most of daniel's life
and
he's not been invited to many parties
he's had no friends he's never had any
friends over and we know of other
parents and i've had parents at daniel's
school hugging me and
all sorts of things this week thanking
me for talking about it and opening up
um
something had to be done so i just
thought the best way of doing it was get
old people that follow daniel and
there's been a few for a long long time
now for various other reasons just to um
understand where we're coming from did i
expect the response we got though no i
didn't
what was the biggest surprise
in terms of the numbers i think um
i've tweeted things before when daniel
was sick a few years ago and got
celebrities suddenly jumping on board
because a lot of people are very very
they just just want to be helpful and be
nice to people
but um i think it was just the numbers
this time that surprised me when my
phone just kept flashing on and off
constantly and just wouldn't stop
um i knew something was going on the
notifications just kept just kept coming
and what about daniel's reaction does he
understand that all these people are are
sort of sending them little virtual
waves and that they're all his friends
i don't think to the degree that
we'd understand he understands or he may
understand he's not really opening up
because he can't express himself in the
same way told a story the other day but
really really did touch him though um i
had this message and i had the little
white box on it said happy birthday
daniel and the screen pulled away and it
was a pilot flying the plane across
america
and
you'd imagine my shock and when i showed
it daniel he was jumping up and down for
joy excited because he likes looking at
playing so i think that i think that
moved him
wow that's fantastic
we've seen her in the pictures and she's
on the wall behind you there dan has got
an older sister how's she coping with
all this attention he's getting are you
getting any hang on i didn't get mark
hamill tweeting me on my 16th birthday
you know i've not been asked that
question and it's a really really
important question
i think you might not be expecting the
response you're going to get
over the years
it's been very hard for hannah and her
daughter
there you go um up that side there you
go um yeah well done it's been very very
difficult it's very very difficult for
siblings of people with um disabilities
because
they sometimes feel that they're being
deprived of attention
they sometimes feel that
nobody cares about them they're not as
important and i'll tell you something i
told somebody yesterday that really
upset her
when
i was taking i used to have hannah and
daddy days last daughter i used to have
hannah and daddy days just to make the
effort to make make her not feel alone
and we were in town and i wasn't feeling
very well and i had to go and get some
water onto my face because i was just
burning up and i came out and hannah was
acting a bit strange and she told me
years later that
she thought that my wife catherine and i
were going to have her adopted because
we couldn't look after both of them
imagine that
no i can't imagine it and i know that it
is a really really hard thing for
families with with one child with a
disability to juggle that um you know
and just not not being able to get
things like respite care is really
really hard it is tough stuff on the
whole family but is she um how is she
with daniel and and how thrilled has she
been at the the attention he's received
yeah sorry jane i didn't really answer
your question i'm like all the
politicians you have on your show not
answering the questions don't worry i'm
not going to shout at you and i'm also
very good at getting what i want to talk
about across i've learned that over the
years now um
hannah is the best
she's like a gift from god for him um
there's my wife and i and hannah's there
as well and she she loves him you should
see the clown and the closeness they
have towards each other i've got
pictures of them sleeping in the bed
together hugging each other um
[Music]
she as she got
into her early teens i think she felt a
little self-conscious about him um and
everything because she wanted to create
her own identity but she's now you know
she's 20 now
and
she's becoming an adult and she just
loves him
she absolutely loves the attention she
is getting at the moment she can't her
exact words were when i told her mark
hamlet
retweeted the story was that's insane
and and that you've you've gone down
this path you know you you've gone out
there and you've spoken publicly about
the impact on your family and on the
impact on daniel but what can other
parents
of kids with autism do to help them to
help perhaps
other families understand about your
child with autism and how important it
is
to make friends and be invited to things
like parties
well the the first thing we have to do
as a society is start to understand that
not everybody has the same
thought process and behaves the same way
especially children
children on the spectrum or children
with additional needs and i would i
could tell you a story of a child i went
to school when i long long time ago now
by 37 years ago that ended up committing
suicide um he was dyslexic and he didn't
realize that when he was 17 or 18 killed
himself and i think about that boy all
the time and we've just got to
understand as a society that you
shouldn't pre-judge people if you see
somebody crying in a restaurant or on a
plane you shouldn't think that they're
misbehaving your first thought shouldn't
be that they're misbehaving you're first
sure
that there might be something wrong what
can we do to help one of my favorite
things i like to do is if i'm in a
coffee shop and i've done it many times
if i see someone struggling i'll buy
them a coffee
just to show them that i care
it's a simple act of kindness that
people should be thinking of doing
we need a better society
i'm starting to pontificate now but over
the last year last two years we've had a
horrendous time over how many thousands
of people have died and we're not
learning anything we've got a polarity
on the right and the left there's a lot
of people in the middle and this is why
this story is really resonated i believe
because a lot of people do care there's
a lot of beautiful lovely people out
there that aren't being heard and i'm
asking those people to start
rising up and
being there for each other
well it's it's a lovely thought it's a
lovely sentiment kev
well done for all you're doing to raise
awareness of autism and we should say
also that you know as kev was talking
about the difficulties people face that
there are lots of organizations out
there to help you um and the samaritans
are always there if you're ever feeling
uh like you need someone to talk to kev
thanks very much best of luck with it
all thank you and i just that that's a
really good point you're never alone i
felt blind in isolation at times um when
you go to bed at night and it's dark and
that's when things start to play on your
mind
yeah you're not alone
kev take care lovely to speak to you
take care thank you
still to come on sky news breakfast
we're going to take a look at the modern
papers with the writer benedict spence
and the broadcaster gemma forte
[Music]
it's been an incredible journey having a
public private partnership working
together with funders
with the governments and the ministries
of health in south africa
esrogini and mozambique we
set out on a journey to eliminate
malaria in our region and for the last
six years have been quite successful in
being able to bring down the number of
cases as well as the number of debts
within the region and we we're not far
away from elimination so it's quite an
exciting time for us
it's a it's a absolute historic
announcement um the world has been
waiting for the first announcement of a
malaria vaccine
and and this announcement uh of the gsk
rtss malaria vaccine
is is particularly important
it it
allows us to add
an additional two into the arsenal that
we have
particularly at a time when
malaria progress has plateaued
since since 2015.
of course even before the pandemic we
were behind the curve with our ambitious
goals for 2030 so bringing on a new tool
adds
adds new energy new vigor for us to get
over the line
as as planned we need to
to put that into context we certainly
believe it has the potential to save
tens of thousands of children
both from cases and death per year but
but the context is that it's got to be
used in combination with the existing
tools that we have
and and that's a very important uh
fact to consider it has to be used um
both with the vector tools so that is
the tools we use against the mosquito so
our bed nets or our indo-residual
spraying program and it's also got to be
done in conjunction with diagnostics and
therapeutics so ensuring that the
children have access to healthcare is is
part of the package that the vaccine
works very well with
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
overnight fog patches over central and
southern england will gradually lift to
warm sunshine it'll be cloudier
elsewhere with outbreaks of rain moving
from scotland northern ireland and the
republic into northern england and wales
skies will brighten later from the west
over ireland and northwest scotland
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high air pollution levels will be
low but isolated pockets of moderate
pollution are possible in urban areas
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
well good morning and with us this
morning to review the papers
writer benedict spencer a few issues
with gemma forte's connection but we'll
hopefully get her to join us very soon
benedict let's just just come to you uh
you were gonna talk first of all about
this year of disruption this is the
front of of the eye newspaper we've been
talking about the winter of discontent
but possibly a spring of discontent as
well it's predicting years of disruption
for britain
yes just rather than winter of
discontent indefinite
discontent which is exactly what
everybody wants to hear after almost two
years of a pandemic or more good news on
the horizon but i suppose you know why
should we expect something to just end
when christmas time ends uh you know
these uh supply chain issues uh fuel
crises uh have been mounting up over
some time and they aren't just undone
with the sort of the stroke of a pen
um anybody who's sort of paying
attention to the wider world will know
that fuel prices are going up in china
you know the price of coal went
parabolic uh there and of course that is
still the world's sort of major
manufacturing hub you then have issues
in the global shipping industry and all
of this you know it ends up affecting us
and there's no end in sight for it i
mean to take sort of one example we talk
a lot about the the shortage of hgv
drivers in this country uh and of course
it emerged that there are tens of
thousands of backlogged applications
from people it's not that the potential
drivers don't exist it's just that their
applications to become drivers haven't
been processed yet and that's not
something that can be sort of sped up
particularly um you know if you've got a
sort of a finite number of employers in
that government department um and that
as as we've said there doesn't appear to
be an immediate end in sight all that
can be done is that the country gets
back to normal or as close to normal as
possible as fast as it can and then
we'll only be going at the rate that we
were before the pandemic but of course
we also have to tread very carefully
there's always you know as smaller
chances there is there is always the
chance that there will have to be sort
of greater uh restrictions covered
restrictions brought back into place
because we don't always we can't foresee
what's going to happen with the virus as
well as the vaccine program is going so
i'm afraid to say that this does look to
be you know well into 2022 we're still
going to be facing a lot of the issues
that we currently are and there's every
chance that a few of them could in fact
get worse oh you're sounding like like
what boris johnson would call a
gloomster uh benedict thanks for that
and gemma you've met gemma you've
managed to join us now and i'm glad
because you wanted to talk about james
brokenshire um who died yesterday of
lung cancer at just 53
tributes from across the political
spectrum to this man i interviewed him
many times and he did genuinely seem
like an incredibly nice chap
and as you say that really is the
feeling that you get from all the
tributes that have been flooding in this
particular one is in the express i mean
it's very sad 53 obviously far too young
and always made even more poignant i
think when you know he's left three
children behind so huge condolences to
them as you say a cross-party outpouring
of respect for a man and i must say the
word that seems to come up in
so many of the tributes is kind and
one particularly also said arguably two
kinds and decent for politics another
person said one of the good guys so it's
it's very sad and lung cancer also i
think it's worth mentioning you know he
didn't smoke so it's
it's very tragic yeah it is and and
you know i think a lot of people talk
about kindness don't they and there's
lots of campaigns on things like twitter
to be kind but
um you know it is lovely to actually
meet somebody and he attributes to
somebody uh using that word it so
expansively
benedict you've picked a story uh from
the inside of the times page four and
this is about employers
losing faith in inflated exam grades
yes this is increasingly becoming the
case but i think the idea that it's just
uh the inflated exam grades of course
will bring everybody back to the debacle
that we had with mr gavin williamson and
sort of predicted grades and how it was
that people were going to be judged
during the pandemic but actually
standard of our education systems
have been dropping for some time and
it's one of those things that people
sort of mutter about they go oh well
exams were harder in my day but but it
is true you know a number of uh major
employers are reporting that they no
longer take gcses a levels and in some
cases degrees into account that they
have to put on special training sessions
for basic things like you know literacy
and numeracy things that should be being
taught in schools but aren't
and you know in many ways you've got to
say yeah good for the businesses for
actually sort of grabbing the bull by
the horns and saying well this is an
issue and we're going to have to sort it
out ourselves but it would be said it's
it's a damning indictment as i say of
the school system it's also a very bad
indictment i think of the university
system which ladens people with you know
huge amounts of debt most of which they
will never get out of to teach them
skills that you know that aren't
necessarily suitable for the job market
which is another thing that this uh
story talks about a lot of people simply
don't have the skills that are required
even though they have university degrees
a lot of universities are telling their
staff that we're possible that they
should ignore spelling and grammar
mistakes on essays and it's just not
good enough i know it might sound a
little bit snobbish but actually you
should demand the very best from your
children in your education system for
their benefit you know not you know for
nothing else then actually you want to
set them up the best possible future
that they can have and the fact that
we've allowed this to sort of slide to
this point where you know
employers no longer necessarily pay
attention to what people studied at
school or university i think that's an
incredibly worrying alarm bell to be
going off and you know it really is
something that needs to be addressed
okay uh
we only got a minute left gemma and we
we've got lots of serious stories but
we've also got some slightly lighter
ones so let's just quickly cut to your
final story and this is about festive
food
concerns about possible shortages of
festive food i can say i had pigs and
blankets yesterday i just thought i
would get it in early in case there was
the predicted pigs and blanket shortage
but what else are we worried about
um
yeah so i'm slightly having trouble
hearing you but i know you can hear me
and i've got the gist so yes this is
about shoppers and one in three people
apparently have already started to uh
get look at getting their turkey in
filling up their freezers i personally
am nowhere near doing this yet but what
i will say is that i don't blame people
necessarily for wanting to get organized
last christmas was awful for all of us
it was pretty joyless we were kate